justice en france la cour de cassation a
rejeté le pourvoi le pourvoi formé par
bernard tapie contre l'arrêt de la cour
d'appel le condamnant dans la sphère au
mv a notamment à deux ans de prison dont
huit mois ferme
celui ci restera donc enfermé quelques
semaines avant de pouvoir bénéficier de
première mesure de libération
conditionnelle ou de remise de peine
levin goldman par ces motifs sur le
pourvoi de bernard tapie le rejette
bernard tapie restera en prison en
rejetant le pourvoi formé par ses
avocats la cour de cassation a adopté le
point de vue soutenu par l'avocat
général
l'immunité parlementaire ne doit pas
protéger un individu mais l'institution
une décision que le député européen
avait envisagé avec ses conséquences
comme il s'était engagé redevenir un
citoyen ordinaire ayant à purger une
condamnation définitive il
démissionnerait de son mandat de député
européen
les avocats de bernard tapie vont
maintenant se livrer à une course contre
la montre dans les deux mois qui
viennent ils vont tenter de le faire
libérer
leur but faire que leur client ne
comparaisse pas prisonniers ici même au
palais de justice de paris dans la
sphère du fossé à bernard tapie
actuellement à la prison de la santé
devra comparaître devant ses juges pour
banqueroute abus de biens sociaux et
fraude fiscale le 28 mars